so we know that you did something to
break me Lisa stress we have yet to
figure out exactly what that is but can
you tease anything when it comes to that
was it dealing with another woman
where are you covering something up well
you know I I will kind of have to keep
that one big as far as like exactly what
happened but you know once again every
relationship has its its challenges
whether it be with trust whether it be
with you know cultural differences you
know if you're dating somebody from a
completely different background and you
know ultimately like there have been
things that have transpired in our
relationship that the viewers will find
out about that have kind of affected her
trust in me and just her trust in the
relationship in general okay well what
did you do to convince her to give you a
second chance to move to Colombia
honestly I feel like not enough you know
and that's so I feel like the viewers
are gonna find out about as well is you
know really how much did I did I how
much have I actually been fighting for
her and how much have I been complacent
you know and I think she's just an
amazing person at really thinking about
me and the relationship and herself
honestly like I think it's just as much
of the decision she's made for herself
as it is for me and the relationship as
far as fighting for this well we know
that you are physically attracted to me
Lisa whatever then her beauty attracts
you to her you know and that's uh that's
a great question and one that I'm happy
to answer because everybody can see how
gorgeous she is you know everybody can
and especially with the whole Colombian
stereotype you know like I think most
people just automatically jump to the
fact that they're stereotypically very
gorgeous
I wouldn't be as attracted to her or you
know for all of the trial and
tribulations that every relationship
goes through if she didn't have more to
her than that you know she's just
incredibly intelligent she's completely
bilingual and you know taught herself a
lot of that she's just really determined
and motivated you know honestly I might
not have as many of those desires to be
motivated or ambitious so that kind of
rubbed off on her so you know just a lot
more things that you look for in a
partner than just beauty because you
know that does fade and she's just an
amazing person she really cares about
other people what do you think it was
about you then Nate I said okay I think
I'm gonna give him a chance you know I
honestly think what made her give me a
chance in the very beginning was just
that I was genuine you know I do fee as
hell and I've really learned to embrace
that and accept that about myself and
the more I kind of continue to do that
and I do that those situations even if
I'm trying to be cool or like spit game
or like sure I was trying and failing
that I think it was just the goofiness
and the fact that she was able to kind
of see that I was trying and I was being
goofy because I don't have any game I
just have the genuine aspect of my
personality why can you tease for us
when it comes to the rest of the season
what will we be seeing from you - I
think there's gonna be a lot of genuine
moments there's gonna be a lot of juicy
moments you know whether it be family
struggle whether it be you know
struggles between me and her whether it
be struggles between adapting to a
completely in place I just think the
viewers are gonna really enjoy getting
to know us as people and as a couple
and kind of being able to really put
themselves in our shoes and kind of
relate you know whether or not they've
been in this specific situation before
or not I think they're gonna be able to
they're gonna be shocked but they're
gonna be delighted to kind of be along
for our riot I think shocked by what I
just I think people are gonna be shocked
by a lot of the things that have
transpired and still continue to
transpire I think people might have
their preconceived notions of where that
may be coming from me or her
you know family members and I think
they're gonna be kind of shocked to find
out really how everything shakes out so
we're in for a ride
[Music]